you've seen them on the big screen and
uncle drew tag and of course the monster
hit get out and now you can check him
out on the smaller screen if you will on
HBO starting tomorrow night his special
premieres then 10:00 p.m. Eastern and
Pacific lil rel Howery live and Crenshaw
on HBO and now live on the Richardson
show good to see you sir
Thank You Man thank you for coming here
this is great I'm very comfortable here
that's a good thing here that's the idea
is we want guests now the problem is for
us too is sometime guests feel so
comfortable they'll start working blue
on our show we've had we've had we just
showed a clip where we showed a few of
the words bleeped out Ed O'Neill came
and dropped like an MF right oh yeah so
which I kind of take as a compliment
that there there's a microphone is so
comfortable like it's like insane we get
you a pillow if you wish yeah I would
just sit here that's the idea good
hey that Congrats on on this this
special and it doesn't look like any
normal specialty shot in a high school
yeah right here in Los Angeles the
Crenshaw that's live in Crenshaw why did
you decide to do that well Jerrod
Carmichael who directed it was his it
was some he pitched to me first he
called me night look man I got an idea
hear me out first yeah but she usually
when he calls and does that is either
about food places cuz I don't try every
day like look I know you don't like sir
stuff but trust me on this okay but uh
he hit me and we when we went to see the
gym and it's like this huge window there
Dorsey high school and the way the light
came in he's like when you walked in it
just felt like it felt like every spot
I've done before when I first started
comedy mm-hmm and I was like oh that's
dope to pay homage to like the beginning
of my career and that's what we did and
we shot it doing today it literally the
Sun sets as I'm onstage is crazy Harvey
what was it a hundred degrees in there
or something like that
Jim high school gym July would it would
a jogging suit oh did you rethink that
one knob I thought it'd be a giraffe
both thought I'd just be cool even just
to see me sweat like it just reminded me
of that ultra those sets I used to do it
I've done gyms and and like Mason halls
and all these different places on shore
and beginning my career so it felt it
felt like a rally I feel like I was
opening for like dr. King ISM right well
I'm telling you the one of the first
things I thought of when I saw some of
the two is also felt like a homecoming
right like or you're kicking off a
season or pep rally or something like
that that's a great way to describe it
felt it felt like that the energy there
was you know was insane which is why I
didn't give a title to the special until
I think was editing it mhm and I
couldn't say live in Dorsey because the
high school was like no you can't use
the high school name you've been in that
cursing no sure
so which is I think a blessing in
disguise or my I would let me what
describes what this was yes Crenshaw
describes it you know and it was you
know we put us from LA like that's not
Christian I see like I'm saying where I
was at right the community that was
there it's just it was Crenshaw and
could the word Christian just describes
that vibe and an experienced man and it
was one of the prior two greatest nights
of my career lil rel Howery here on the
Rich Eisen show what's the greatest
night you've had in a gym otherwise
though oh how many points several
several guys about to say how many
points have you put up I can run I used
to ball out like like that's why I'm a
sadist I don't say I keep saying those
stuff okay I want to play in the
celebrity game it's gonna be in Chicago
this year well huh I promised you I'd do
twenty and ten twenty ten and six the 10
is 10 assists 10 assists 6 rebounds or
20 points like I'm like you know people
be just playing around these games oh no
no no no no I'm going to play as hard
and like you go see me sweating in the
layup line like Kevin Hart was messing
with me like you're gonna do all that
prepared but you go get hurt the first
quarter
you can tell your chilies in the first
school but now I really want to play
because I want to ball out like I play
why won't you give yourself four more
rebounds oh no I have come over bro I'm
just being real just go ahead twenty ten
and six twenty ten and six okay I can do
that would you want to create your own
team here I don't matter with 2010 it's
a twenty ten and six just get me to
borrow fan how are you how are you gonna
get to twenty Jimmy I'll get the two I
wanna shake three I mean at the style
the style not going I'm just gonna take
a lot of shots like are you gonna get
the tennis since then brought so this is
how I'm gonna do it right
Kyrie put up a Kyrie teller Aaron Gordon
is always do uncle drew just how to
think about everything per quarter yeah
you know okay so if I do about I didn't
do six in the first quarter right you
know they may not play me in the second
quarter can I gotta play to other
celebrities six the first quarter right
for the second quarter okay just come
back at the halftime I'm warmed up now
I'm warmed up right you're warmed up I
can probably do 10 in the third they
probably sent me some of the fourth when
I come back at a fourth quarter
I'm just dishing the boss tributing
that's what it is yeah once you get your
twenty once I got the timer I'm good
okay so that's when you did 20 out the
way and I'm gonna distribute a ball and
I'm gonna look the rebound
every time I'm crashing the board but
that's what Lil rohauer here on the
richezza show that's why I'm asking you
if you want to create your own team
because when you distribute somebody's
got to make the shot otherwise you don't
get the assist we tell you something so
I'm saying if Mugsy Bogues decide to
play one of these games that would be
who I would love to be on my team
Muggsy Bogues he's not gonna shoot it
he's gonna get you to bow but when you
distribute somebody's got it somebody's
got a somebody's gonna I know it's
people like comment you know okay I've
thought about this tio Terrell Owens has
got some game you know you can't hoop so
tio on the wing yes right yeah you come
down you break down
you go down the lane you break down the
defense you distribute Chris Brown like
Chris Brown Kahoot like Brett I've
thought about that's why I'm again
that's why I'm trying to walk you
through I want to help you succeed at
this no I want any Arne Duncan let's get
Barack Obama Chicago might be the best
celebrity all-star game by the way if
it's Chicago yeah
again I don't I just don't know it's
funny cuz my kids I know your kids are
over here on the on our on our green
room couch over here my kids watch the
match singer I don't know if your kids
do that too okay that my kids they just
talked about it too my kids think
everybody in the mask singer could
possibly be Barack Obama and I say to my
kids I say to my kids because I've given
up saying look it's not Obama in there
okay I have told my kids any Obama name
it Michelle Barack Sasha Malia any Obama
gets revealed to be in amassing a
hundred dollars to all of my children
here you go so now but that's added an
extra you know area of excitement here
comes the reveal up its Patti LaBelle
okay I get to keep my hundred bucks it's
interesting to kids think that the
Obamas could sing look Mike he's old
record he sounds terrorism priest
impress that he's sung it but it wasn't
it really no careful you want them on
your team yeah but I'm saying can't see
you just need to make the shot he
literally sang in his talking voice mmm
people's oh that's great I'm like no
it's not I wish I was dead aback come on
yeah what what are we doing this is the
worst let's stay together they are in
the Rich Eisen show give me some other
Kyrie Nuggets from from shooting well
you know true not even just Kyrie late
Reggie Miller can really
shoot why I mean we know that right yeah
but the seed in person is fascinating we
was all in Dave & Buster's at Dave &
Buster's in we did it uncle drew hmm and
you know they get the little basketball
machine sure they legit was like going
Emma Kyrie was going even on Papa Schadt
head yes they was going at it in too
much Reggie hit liked in stir it was
crazy
hmm oh my god way too competitive this
is not even a real basketball room we
had Lisa Leslie here and she kind of
confirmed that she was the best of all
we taste on the set they pay they played
those games you saw like those
basketball scenes we was with a really
was playing right Lisa got hot it was it
was been a felt like the Rucker
the extras was going she got hot for
real
now day was on like we played in years
which I don't believe none of them clean
alone time we get on the court and it
was just like a switch went off and you
like you I can't believe I'm doing this
movie with these ladies that yo she
caught fire is it true six threes in a
row six threes in a row she called fire
bro it was crazy to watch that that's
right
you know I mean the movies out now but
like when I hit the game-winning shot
you know that was the first take I was
like and I kept missing so the extra
start getting irritated cuz I wouldn't
hit another shot the extras are getting
I started getting heckled by the extras
like come on man what's wrong with you
right and hip curl what about staying in
your lane in this regard which of the
players has the best comedic chops
Chris Webber how about that Chris Webber
was even stutter right c-webb hysterical
really I honestly he needs to be more
stuff I think he's really good it lacks
he surprised me late and it annoyed me
to be the same thing like
Griffen doing stand-up like he did you
know Blake Griffin does stand-up yeah he
was he does the he did the roast stuff
with Jeff Ross don't stand up at the
Just for Laughs festival couple years
and I'm all the commune's we came to
watch League like kind of like give him
he'll
and he was like really good it was all
like this is messed up I can just show
up it at a basketball facility they
start playing just kind of my job I do
that to Blake Griffin he's actually got
the chop he's really much c-webb see
where it was amazing that's amazing
yeah little rel Howery few more minutes
left with him here on the Rich Eisen
show so you get the I guess notice or
invitation to be in a Jordan Peele movie
yeah did you think get out was gonna be
what was handed to you when you just it
just a top-line message you're gonna be
in the Jordan Peele movie well even more
than it when Jordan Jordan told me about
it at a party man he's I wrote a horror
film I'm like alright good luck with
that but in the more he kept describing
it and I might bring you really this is
your thing and I don't think none of us
thought it was gonna do what it did I I
thought it was too thick either people's
gonna either embrace it over like you
know this is crazy
if you get all yeah and I think that's
the good thing too because all of us
went into it the intention was just if
this is a great written film and we
always fans of Jordan so for it to
become this thing and there's a see
everybody kind of blowing do these
differently like Daniel kahlúa like just
his fascinating writing I mean the guy
won an Oscar he's got a statuette on his
mantle with get out he's brilliant and
and that was it was free only shot that
like 28 days is that right yeah I think
I did everything in a week so when you
go through airports do TSA guys give you
a shout out cuz that's what you played
they show low but they don't give me no
special privileges
yeah we know you do your arms like this
like everybody else
so yeah they show love no it's very it's
like when I when it first came out and I
think the TSA always got bad rap but I'm
like yeah you know they help keep us
safe right as much as we get mad and
irritate about it they're just doing a
job correct yeah they must love you in
the film but still you just feel like a
man right we know who you is brother but
shoes shoes get everything after packets
man well congrats on me on the HBO
special and everything that's going on
with you too and I do want to I guess
reconnect before this NBA all-star game
you tell you what I'm gonna do
starting probably maybe in another week
or two I'm gonna start filming myself
getting ready for this okay I haven't
been selected yet imma literally do a
mini documentary too cuz I'm gonna start
making phone calls now because I need
this to happen I need to play in this
gang with me you're gonna hit LeBron I'm
gonna hit LeBron apply bro you got to
put it a word for me brother well I
think that's all he's got to do right
right I'm gonna I'm gonna call in favors
and I'm also gonna really work out so
I'm gonna really start getting in
basketball like I'm a shape button to my
basketball shape hmm so get these shots
up but I'm gonna start filming this yes
it's gonna be a little mini documentary
just of me getting ready for a game I
haven't been selected to yet okay you be
sad about did others would you mind if I
offered my voiceover services for this
video if you want to do that that'll be
doing fact in okay I mean I am too I'm
not just saying that if you are going to
make a video admit a documentary to
submit to whoever makes the decision as
to who makes an all-star NBA all-star
Celebrity roster in Chicago I mean I'm
I'm way in for that so just send me I'll
do it and then I love series you do are
fact
this is a microphone in front of me I
talk into it I will read it I would work
blue if you want me to do that too I
should make this a 30 for 30 there
should be a 30 or like a six for six
24:10 2010 is 6 2010 6 it's gonna be the
stat line 22 6 I'm like take me out
we've come on seriously clickable
exchange information and we'll do this
lil rel Howery at lil rel for on Twitter
at comedian lil rel on Instagram and
check out lil rel Howery
live in Crenshaw on HBO that premieres
tomorrow night at 10 p.m. Eastern and
Pacific you can also catch at this very
weekend on HBO go and HBO now and
available on demand this Sunday good to
see you
thank you brother we'll be part of the
side where this is great I just came up
with something when we come back your
phone calls at 8 for 4 204 rich actually
Mayan NFL picks no your Chris Brockman
you're gonna give us your pics right
yeah we're gonna sneak in games and then
Mark Cuban will be on the show hey I can
say to Cuban he's Pinos some people -
yeah Mark Cuban it he's no not here he's
on the phone he's just probably watching
all his Lord on Shark Tank stuff we can
do that Mark Cuban is coming out - don't
go in her for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on VR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app